welcome to the 60th annual Academy
Awards
Hollywood this year's nominees
mr. bunny Roger
to win Academy Award Liza Minnelli will
introduce best song nominees
a three-time nominee and a winner of the
coveted Oscar mister Rod Steiger and ask
Oscar winner last year with her subpoena
if mr. James Brooks fades underway to
present her in the Foreign Language Film
category Richard Dreyfuss former Oscar
winner former domination
final question [ __ ] is mr. Lewis
new gusset former Oscar
his rollin off certain gentlemen
presenter Darrell Hemet who appeared in
Roxanne in Wall Street this year
a macho heartthrob Tom Selleck who will
present the animated short term award
here's hee
from John teller
tonight glamorous Jennifer Grey who
starred in Dirty Dancing the supporting
actor can refer moonstruck mr. Vincent
gardenia mr. Michael Douglas a Best
Actor hopeful for Wall Street the
co-producer of fatal attraction
beautiful Sherry Lansing from the
accounting firm of Price Waterhouse she
tabulate the ballotine guaranteed the
secrecy and integrity of the results mr.
Frank Johnson and mr.
Best Supporting Actress nominee for girl
train and Remzi gorgeous candy Bergen
with Louie ball he's a double nominee of
this evening a presenter in the
cinematography category dashing Mel
Gibson a star of The Last Emperor the
presenter tonight John Lowe nominated as
Best Supporting Actress news an archer
for his directing efforts in moonstruck
comedy Norman Jewison two-time Oscar
winner Jack Lemmon presenting the
Faubourg award
Olympia Dukakis a Canada and Best
Supporting Actress category
so they great night I don't use
for this you got to do it
I can't blade it had a good time nice to
see you again good to see you
don't let all these famous people people
with elegant poles and limousines
looking so cool for you because
underneath this is a pretty nervous
group with only one thing in their minds
you know why because they are the actors
writers producers directors and
technicians who made the pictures we're
going to honor tonight and now find
themselves as Oscar nominees
ah
would be my one and only chance I hope I
get the top place is pretty taco Fraggle
history rather really up to this kind of
contest
I'm nominations body dr. competition
so many tears the way they baked it how
many years I got it
grabbin my plates and then you're
drooling blaming the thanks like movie
cooling I got a heart protector breakin
60th year I'll never make it one to work
gets a doorstop casteist I neglected
only back in the spotlight a guest is
expected here brother
he is here go find another
thank you
brother
and
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences mr. Robert Wise
welcome to the 60th anniversary of the
Academy Awards we have an evening of the
extraordinary nominees and absolutely
unpredictable outcomes and for you and
we're going to enjoy it all enormously
to make the occasion just a shade more
festive I have a remarkable piece of
news for everyone everyone in the world
who cares deeply about the art of motion
pictures I've delighted to report that
the Academy has concluded an agreement
this week with the city of Beverly Hills
that will provide a new home for our
burgeoning library and film archive in
one of the city's most historic
buildings when the necessary
architectural our contextual restoration
work has been done the career papers of
industry giants from Mack Sennett for
Alfred Hitchcock the historical records
of major of minor studios and all the
other extraordinary materials in our
collection will be housed under one
magnificent Spanish Romanesque roof so
thank you so
so for those of you who asked what the
economy does on the days when we're not
giving out oscars you have an invitation
to come visit in about a year and we'll
have a dazzling answer for you then and
now for the night when we do give out
Oscars you distinguished men and women
who have been nominated for an Academy
Award this year have moved as thrilled
as broadus laughter and tears and we're
grateful to you for the pleasure of your
achievements god I hope you all can get
it now ladies and gentlemen here is
someone who's also moved as thrilled us
brought us laughter in tears but never
got a nomination for it the state last
year we dropped him through a trapdoor
almost had him eaten by a plant my
favorite master of ceremonies the
handsome talented only slightly bruised
mr. Chevy Chase
good evening Hollywood phonies
welcome to Tinseltown the Athens of the
West this is it the biggest night of the
year tonight will mark the beginning for
a very few lucky people and the end of a
lot of friendships now as most of you
know by now there is a writer's strike
so just so you understand none of this
material has been written by me a guild
member or any other writer unless done
so before and in anticipation of a
pending strike in fact my entire
monologue was generously donated by five
Teamsters the strike does present us
with some problems and some advantages
it will substantially shorten the show
since there will be nothing for anybody
to say so let's get right to it shall we
bertolucci Nicholson
I just came
the weird
tonight we've got a great lineup of
presenters who don't need the written
word to express themselves out here and
just in case I do remember there may be
a writer's strike but there is not a
reader strike tonight we have more big
stars in any year I can remember of
course I can't vouch much for my
short-term memory I lost a few tiles on
reentry but it is a terrific lineup be a
lot of funny comedians who are used to
winging it and that's lucky for us
because as you know the names of the
nominees were not known before the
strike so none of them could actually be
written out on the envelopes or on the
cue cards means we're actually just
gonna have to guess or go with our best
instincts so I'd like to offer my
apologies in advance to those of you who
are unmentioned this evening this is not
all together out of keeping with most
Academy Award years in which many names
who should have been mentioned have been
forgotten I can't think of a year in
motion pictures with more quality
performances or more critically
acclaimed films it's a real horse race
in 1988 and most of the nominated stars
are here which is very unusual the women
are beautiful and many of the men have
showered Glenn Close is here
then closes here with our obstetrician
just in case anything out of the
ordinary pops up and I have it on good
authority that cher will be in fact
dressed we currently have decided
against the simple but elegant wardrobe
of just the dress shields and
odor-eaters and is going for the full
body covering
two of my favorite comedians Albert
Brooks and Robin Williams are up for
acting awards always a good sign for the
comedy community
which brings me to the subject of
critics now many feel a movie can be
made or broken by a critic you have some
of the most delightful and successful
films have been panned obviously not by
the audiences
critics are a strange species imagine a
parent saying son when you grow up I
want you to spend all your time going to
the movies then I want you to make a
living writing about what a terrible
experience it's been then maybe you can
get a job on TV see critics or guys like
well you know the one who says I don't
know what they're smoking in Hollywood
but if I see another one of his movies
of them out out of the business now guys
like that oh sure some of the real
people and for the most part they're
there to enlighten and educate an
opinion a analyse and to tear apart the
work of hundreds of artists over a
two-year period in the space of two
minutes but good film criticism can be
thought of as an art form so this year
the Academy is closely considered giving
out an award in a new category best
movie critic unfortunately we found
there weren't any we did over
however come up with the following
possible categories strangest on-screen
behavior by a critic critic most looking
like a dripping candelabra critic with
the strangest hair choices most
long-winded written critic and finally
TV critic couple most in love with
themselves or each other let's face it
without us where would the critics be
you know where we'd be if we didn't have
them and now quite seriously a word
about the rules all eligible Academy
members are asked to vote for
nominations for Best Picture other
nominations are voted by members who are
specialists in each field results of the
secret voting are known only to the
independent accounting firm of Price
Waterhouse girls in the office Nancy
Catherine Marty oh of course myself and
Janey my wife and kids a couple of
friends ballots will then be tabulated
and the winners will be chosen honestly
and according to the following criteria
if you're old and you have won one yet
if you're relatively young or too funny
and your name begins with Steve or
Steven you are ineligible if you live in
the neighborhood and your movies up for
Best Picture you cannot be nominated for
Best Director if you make fitness videos
or commercial for commercials for
fitness centers you are eligible beards
are out and of course this simply will
not do